[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de vip
aujourd'hui nous recevons thomas bayer
vous êtes réalisateur et acteur
originaire de villepreux bourges
alors votre premier court métrage
professionnel sera diffusé le 4 décembre
1h04 sur france 2 il s'appelle deux
soeurs et dure près de 20 minutes
c'est un court métrage un court métrage
pardon que j'ai trouvé moi très touchant
poignant il est question de deux soeurs
qui dansent ensemble et un accident
survient est ce que vous pouvez faire un
petit résumé
effectivement alors c'est un court
métrage qui sera diffusé à l'occasion
des 30 ans cette année lyon du téléthon
sur france 2
c'est un court métrage qui a été produit
par les films de l'instant bien garni et
coréalisé et coécrit avec mon amie laure
duthilleul
ces deux ans d'écriture sur un thème
très simple qui est les relations et la
fratrie
lorsqu'il ya dans une famille un enfant
malade ou en situation de handicap
mais cette fois ci est à l' inverse de
ce qu on peut voir très souvent axés sur
le patient
on a voulu s'intéresser un petit peu à
la vie des accompagnants et notamment du
frère ou de la soeur alors pour ce court
métrage là il s'agit donc de la soeur
qui effectivement bava un peu perdre
pied et se sentir vraiment coupable et
culpabiliser sur sur l'accident que qui
va se produire pour sa soeur sont deux
soeurs qui ont toujours dansé ensemble
et qui sont promises à un avenir assez
incroyable
mais voilà le destin fait qu' on a une
des deux qui se blesse gravement et là
le couperet tombe elle ne dansera plus
donc comment l'une va réussir à combler
un petit peu ce vide se rêve en vivent
effectivement cette ambition à travers
sa soeur qui elle est toujours valide et
comment l'autre soeur par culpabilité va
essayer de trouver des choses un petit
peu pour tourner autour et le clash
arrive lorsqu'elle apprend que sa soeur
ne danse plus qu'elle lui manque c'est
cette cause c'est à partir de cette
reconstruction qu'on a travaillé sur le
film et voilà et donc pourquoi avoir
fait un court métrage sur ce sujet
écoutez est en moi toucher de près par
une maladie chronique génétique
il m'a semblé assez légitime est assez
normal de pouvoir travailler sur ce
sujet qui me tient à coeur mais j'espère
que ce n'est qu'un début puisque
justement avec l'ordre nous sommes en
train d'écrire
nous avons déjà vingt pages ce qu'on
appelle la phase de développement du
premier long mais demont prune de notre
premier long métrage heures pour l'heure
et on a déjà réalisé mais le mien ce
sera le premier où là on accentue
vraiment un film d'une heure trente 1h45
sur la relation d'une famille de quatre
axé sur cette soeur qui vit aussi le
handicap de son frère pas de manière
physique mais de manière psychologique
et on suit un peu son parcours d'ado
vers lé jeune adulte il serait il
sortira quand c'est un long métrage
alors ce long métrage on peut pas encore
parler de sortie ou quoi nous on est à
la recherche d'un producteur
je pense que l'on rentrera dans une dans
un travail d'écriture juste après pour
un long métrage
il n'ya pas ya pas de règles c'est à
dire que c'est un une écriture qui peut
durer entre six mois et un an et demi ce
sont des étapes validé avant de lancer
le feu vert pour le tournage
mais c'est vrai que depuis tant que
j'attende de faire ce film
les étapes arrivent les unes derrière
les autres et c'est plutôt chouette pour
en revenir à 2 heures il a été tourné
dans le coin plaisir ville proches des
lieux que vous connaissez c'était un
choix alors c'est des lieux que je
connais puisque moi je suis originaire
donc de villepreux je suis à wimereux
je sais une ville où je me sens bien et
puis j'ai trouvé l'occasion de pouvoir
obtenir des décors sur ces lieux là il
ya plaisir aussi au niveau des gâtines
dans le film mais également une piscine
j'ai besoin on avait besoin d'une d'une
fosse de 20 mètres donc cette piscine se
trouve à villeneuve la garenne
donc voilà c'est resté autour autour de
la maison
dans mes repères en fait quel était le
processus pour qu'il soit diffusé n'est
pas encore diffusée mais il va l'être
est un processus vous avez été avec le
téléthon alors en fait lorsqu'on a
commencé
le travail d'écriture on était vraiment
faim de travail d'écriture il s'est posé
le problème du financement
donc c'est donc le travail qui a été
fort needham le ventre et par les
producteurs de rechercher et bien des
apports pour réaliser le film et un
moment donné il a été question de le
proposer à laurence thierno qui est la
présidente du téléthon
mais il ya quelque chose là dedans qui
me dérange un petit peu et je suis très
heureux que mes producteurs mais suivi
là dessus c'est à dire que je fais ce
film pour mettre la lumière
effectivement sur le patient mais
surtout sur ses frères et soeurs et je
trouvais pas légitime d'aller chercher
de l'argent qui peut servir à la
recherche ou bien à aider les familles
dans leur quotidien pour faire un film
en fait
et tandis que ce film est pour eux
j'avais pas envie qu'on se servent de
leur argent pour voilà pour faire un
film et on a réussi à le faire
d'une autre manière et je trouve ça
d'autant mieux aujourd'hui puisque le
film leur est complètement dédié
si on ne parle pas assez des personnes
qui accompagnent des personnes en
situation de handicap ou malades
eh bien non avec l'or on s'est aperçu
puisque elle a aussi l'expérience elle a
fait beaucoup de documentaires notamment
un sur les familles avec les enfants
atteints de maladie très lourde et
et ça a été une véritable rencontre avec
elle parce qu'on a partagé tout de suite
ce sujet et elle m'a fait comprendre
qu'elle m'a appris que rapport aux états
unis où on est très axé sur l'entourage
la famille ont fait beaucoup plus
attention c'est pas un reproche mais en
france on est très axé sur le patient
son quotidien
les avancées est effectivement autour et
bahia des familles notamment les parents
mais surtout voilà moi je suis surtout
sur les frères et soeurs qui
effectivement ne ne sont pas atteints
physiquement mais psychologiquement
c'est à dire comment vivre avec la
culpabilité d'avoir un frère ou une
soeur malade accepter de vivre sa vie
d'être heureux de partager aussi ces
problèmes parce que quand on est
adolescent là aussi des problèmes mais
on se dit bah je vais pas parler des
problèmes à la maison puisqu'il ya déjà
beaucoup de problèmes avec mon frère ou
ma soeur c'est un enfermement en fait
qui grandit en même temps que que notre
on devient adulte en fait
et au bout d'un moment parfois parfois
pas parfois c'est uniquement après le
recul quand on a 30 40 ans mais parfois
expérience m'a montré que arrivé à l'âge
adulte
on commence à où on explose où on n'a
aucune confiance en soi on a beaucoup de
mal à gérer ses émotions
on en veut peut-être parfois à ses
parents et c'est là que le conflit
s'établit et que le dialogue se faire
mais il faut touche surtout pas que le
dialogue se faire masser bon voilà ses
frères et soeurs ou le droit d'exister
ils ne sont rien responsable de la
maladie de leurs frères ou soeurs leurs
parents non plus d'ailleurs donc voilà
je pense qu'avec la communication et du
dialogue
on arrive à de belles choses mais c'est
vraiment ce qu'on ressent voyant l
infini et donc pour en revenir à votre
parcours vous avez fait les cours
florent
vous avez joué dans plusieurs films
notamment l'incroyable histoire du
facteur cheval
donc vous êtes à la fois réalisateur
acteur c'est un choix vous voulez
continuer dans cette double casquette et
m'ont effectivement je souhaite
continuer dans cette double casquette
quand j'ai commencé les cours florent
c'était vraiment pour devenir acteur
j'ai eu la chance
le connaître très jeune qui celui qui
est maintenant mon ami un peu mon papa
dans le cinéma c'est niels tavernier qui
n'est pas un homme de piston c'est à
dire qu' il ne m'a jamais fait de cadeau
il n'a jamais il a toujours été très
franc sur ce qu'ils pensaient de moi de
mon travail
il m'a toujours poussé
et je le remercie aujourd'hui parce que
c'est aussi grâce à ça que j'ai cette
ténacité et que j'ai pu développer les
les projets que qui me tiennent à coeur
donc effectivement il m'a fait jouer
dans le facteur cheval mais par exemple
j'ai passé le casting notamment sans lui
pour que la directrice de casting elle
son mot à dire
puis j'ai aussi tourné dans le film
d'albert dupontel qui était encore à
l'affiché avant cette période de nouveau
confinement
mais en parallèle j'ai toujours écrit
c'est à dire que j'avais réalisé deux
clips avant de rentrer cours florent et
un premier court métrage qui a remporté
le premier prix florent images locaux en
2010 cet essai suite à ça que niels m'a
dit écoute lance-toi vraiment aussi dans
la réalisation
si tu as besoin de conseils je serai la
six a besoin d'être lu je serai là mais
est un vrai sujet à défendre et il faut
que tu ailles jusqu'au bout et c'est
pour ça que je suis en train avec l'or
et avec l'aide des producteurs de faire
mon petit bonhomme de chemin et donc au
delà de la réalisation est ce qu'il ya
d'autres projets à venir du coup plutôt
en tant qu'acteur alors autant d'acteurs
moi là je viens d'être retenu pour une
un rôle principal dans une série
france 2 donc ces départs en tournage à
cette mi décembre et au mois de janvier
également je continue à passer beaucoup
de casting et a travaillé sur
le développement de ce premier long
métrage et vous comptez rester dans les
yvelines pour elle habitait pour
l'instant j'y suis bien j'ai ma famille
ma compagne tout est tout va très bien
ça me permet de pouvoir m'évader j'aime
beaucoup marcher en forêt ça me permet
aussi de réfléchir de comprendre
certaines choses ça m'inspire donc oui
j'aime bien j'aime bien c'est quoi et si
vous aviez un grand rêve professionnel
ce serait quoi
et bien le premier rêve professionnel
qui me vient l'heure actuelle c'est
effectivement au delà de réaliser ce
projet ce premier long métrage c'est de
faire la promotion de ce film un petit
peu partout en france et de rencontrer
ses frères et soeurs et leur dire
réellement vous avez le droit de vivre
vous avez le droit de d'avoir peur vous
avez le droit de vous exprimer mais
parlez-en et les gens sont là autour
suis pas un donneur de leçons vis-à-vis
des parents mais avec l'or on essaye
plutôt d'être comme une petite cloche
confessions et peut-être une alerte fait
attention
le patient va mal mais le frère ou la
soeur peut aller mal aussi il faut être
là est présent et c'est vraiment ce
message que j'ai envie de faire
véhiculer un petit peu en france à
travers ses films est en projet
personnel un projet personnel se filmer
est un projet personnel m'épanouir aussi
dans ma vie privée
voilà très bien merci beaucoup thomas
maillet d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que le court métrage sera
diffusé le 4 décembre sur france 2 merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette émission
à bientôt
il